alors pile ou face
c'est pile sur la
première seconde première 3e première
10 5 1 6 25 et 4
[Musique]
monsieur renard vous la parole 739 1 39
peu ce qui arrive et rebecca ricky
ribéry 7 45 7 45 c'est monsieur renard
qui parle alors 4 - 1 3 oui
trois fois 25 75 75 oui fois dix sept
cent cinquante sept cent cinquante cinq
et six ans que j'aurais tranche 2 757
130 1739 d'accord oui avec 749 je vous
donne
5 x 6 e 30
30 x 25 750
moins 10 740 + 1 741
voilà six points par circulaire dont
quatre points pour monsieur renard et
c'est un monsieur caries kyriba vols
annuels
voyelles
voyelles à voyelles et consonnes
j
consonne s voyelles e et voyelles pas
[Musique]
top monsieur carrez qui ribéry s'est
incliné sur l'art une chose aisée au
féminin oui
c'est avec grand plaisir que nous
tournons vers mac c'est vrai et bien
voilà j'ai le grand plaisir même vous
présenter madame
michèle de sa vie on vous entend nous
attendent et passe la dernière fois on
avait des plantes vertes des tapis rouge
il avait été retenu par jour et nous les
médias tendent alors vous avez vu que la
télévision à petit côté artisanal ça ne
vous a pas échappé une consultante
c'était une grande entreprise
industrielle pas du tout et on fait un
peu de toi la mer il était très
sympathique de toi sympathie l'ambiance
est très bonne ob alors patrice thibaud
mais si vous êtes dans une grande salle
et vous mes estimés à 4 en faveur de
monsieur renard encore en faveur de
monsieur carrick et ribéry là j'ai bien
dire après ça va bien pour les
airs qu'on sonne t consonnes des
consonnes et voyelles
aux voyelles e moyenne
et voyelles
[Musique]
top monsieur renard cette lettre
monsieur carrick et ribéry à part entier
pardon routier routier
max est un v8 avec droiture exactement
sept points pour monsieur renard qui
reprend la tête 11la 5
et le match continue avec les chiffres
premières
secondes 1re 3e hominem 4e
7 de 9
75 6 et 3
[Musique]
monsieur carrez qui ribéry ça s'arrose
monsieur renard le compte est bon bruit
75 x 7 525
69 x 7 à
9 et 10 15 que je retranche de 525 que
ça fait 510 le temps mais je vous avais
dit ensuite 9 et 6 15 6 15 oui j'ai
entendu deux fois ci ça m'étonne un peu
510 parfait
et bien bravo monsieur renard là vous
fait une belle opération 17 à 5 c'est à
vous de parler pour les lettres
consonnes est 100 tonnes des consonnes
ses
voyelles aux voyelles
e voyelles
et consonnes
s ses voyelles
[Musique]
e
à
sur l'a7 lettre monsieur carrick calibre
et boisés ou féminin pluriel voit ses bo
é
se2 et c'est bien de s'écarter je ne
sais pas pourquoi
un problème max nox et la vie de madame
desseigne en tout cas oui très bon
parcours de monsieur renard monsieur
carrick et ribéry il faut
24 à 5 c'est à vous voyez là y voyait à
son voyelles
voyelles
y consonnes et
conson
elle
voyelles
et consonnes
s
[Musique]
je vous écoute cinq lettres mais sur la
mieux payée
féminin
pays et y ai filé plèbe ali et ses
terribles saint point pour monsieur
carrez qui ribéry 24 à10 les chiffres
monsieur roy la première
première première 1ère 3e première
10 à
25 9 3 et 6
[Musique]
et
sur la 597
alors 25 - 24 24 oui
9 et 6 15 et 10 25 6 x 24 600 600 wii -
3 - 3
solution je lis souvent kg de papier
neuf fois
6,54 +3 57 x 10
577 points 25 595
424 points 28 à 10
et la sonnerie finale
qui voit monsieur cakir béribéri dans
une carie qui ribéry dans une position
assez défavorable pour le moment 28 à 10
ce sera relativement difficile vous
commencerez la prochaine fois avec les
lettres et nous espérons tous bien sûr
que fabien sera aussi brillant qu'il est
ce soir c'est vraiment remarquable n'est
ce pas monsieur renard faut dire
qu'elle est contre moi vraiment vous
avez raison mais aussi chanteur colère
contre vous mais ce qu'harry béret
carrick qui ribéry en plus voilà une
fille nommée trouveront la prochaine
fois tous ensemble j'essayais de
m'exercer d'ici là je vous souhaite à
tous une très bonne soirée
[Musique]